foreign
[Music]
first of all congratulations on this
film it's absolutely amazing thank you
so much fun thank you
um you know I feel a little obsessed
with we are lady Parts uh I was
um I used to coordinate our spirit
Awards nominating committees so I was on
the TV committee that were coordinating
the year of we are lady parts
and I won't say who it we always have a
lot of Industry people on those panels
I won't say who it was because it's a
recognizable name but one of the women
on that panel is a Muslim American
filmmaker and a writer and when we
talked about we are lady Parts she just
made the speech that made me cry she was
just like
I don't know if you know how important
this project is but we need it's we need
to lift it up not only because it's
freaking fantastic but it's
representation that's just we just
haven't had before
and so I wanted to ask you
you had an interesting Journey with we
are lady parts right the the your first
the first reception was sort of drove
you off of social media because people
were unkind
so I wanted to ask how did you get from
where our lady parts to here what do you
think that Journey was
yeah no thank you for that
um oh I actually wrote the first draft
of this film before I even attempted
lady Parts it was 10 years ago I wrote
the first draft for this and it was just
wild and you know it was trying to do
all the genres and it was the first
thing I'd written out of film school
um but I couldn't get the film made and
actually television opened up for me in
a way that film didn't
um I started working directing pilots
and you know in the UK directing
um you know writing kids television and
I got my show we are lady Parts green
lit and that was an incredible
experience it was where I found my voice
I found what I wanted to say the things
I care about the genre I like to work in
but it was also where I experienced that
sort of backlash
um where I felt you know not everyone
loved what I do what I wanted to do but
you know going through that was so
um you know incredibly empowering for me
it it gave me the confidence to make
polite Society it made me think actually
I can stick to my guns about what I and
who I am and what I want to stay say
because just for making we are lady
Parts I felt that you can't please
everyone when you're doing
representation you've just got to stick
to what you know in your own personal
truth and that's what you know really
gave me the confidence and also the
resource to get to make polite Society
at this level with a studio yeah
so what um what inspired this uh this
story in this film your your writer
director on it what inspired the story
of polite Society
I've been reflecting on this recently
and I you know I I studied martial arts
as a teenager I I have an older sister
who's one year older than me and we used
to fight together you know
actually in you know martial arts class
but also out of the Class A lot as well
and I remember like fighting with her in
class and then like getting smacked down
to the ground and feeling the physical
pain of having my face hit the floor but
also the humiliation of teenagers
laughing at you and there's something in
that moment of like being a teenage girl
and the pain of that and it working with
action and I really I think in that
moment like I need to make an action
movie about what it feels like to be a
teenage girl I think yeah and this
teenage girl's like really I think fight
each other though
like that scene that fight in the
bedroom where she shoves her face into
the uh the picture yeah
that birds are with the hair straight I
was like this is real it's what it feels
like to fight with your sister what what
was it that that made you know you you
wanted to take it that far did you just
feel like if we take it this far it's
gonna be super funny and super yeah just
thrilling I just needed to take it that
far because actually I wished my sister
could have been there we watched it
together and held each other crying yeah
just because it's what it felt like I
have a feeling you're kind of punk rock
but yeah my sister kicked my ass Lots um
when I was grown up so I had to kind of
work through some yeah
how about a for you Priya did you come
into this knowing anything about martial
arts or was this something that that you
had to learn for for the film
I knew absolutely zilch like are you in
Canada
yeah I knew nothing I've never done
martial arts before I've never done
stunts like this before and I was cost
about like six or seven weeks before we
started the shoot so we did a really big
deep dive and it was really important to
me that I did as much of all of the
stunts as I possibly could because it's
so important to Ria like I it was kind
of meta like I got to be a stuntwoman
which is what Ria wants to be
um which is amazing and I I attempted
everything because I because I checked
on you like I watched it at home this
this week and passed it on parts of the
fight scene that's you it's me I was
trying to I was trying to pause and
catch a double in there just no there's
no double
I do have an incredible job on Erin who
um really was such a guiding like for me
I I learned so much through even
imitating her
um but we had such an empowering stunt
team they really encouraged me to do as
much of it as I could and and they knew
how important it was to me to do as much
as I could I was like you know step
aside Tom Cruise where we're doing this
thank you
I know what's up with Tom Cruise he's
always hurting himself no the guy has to
chill now
I bet you never hurt yourself at all
never
he might also be about 50 years younger
than him but
um so what's how did you know that it
was Priya talk about the first time do
you guys remember your first meeting
and how did you know prayer Was Your
Girl
I mean we were struggling to find
someone who could play this but I didn't
really didn't think I had a movie
um for a long time and we were getting
close to the wire and then
I saw Prius tape and I'm like oh
I've seen this and then when she came in
you know just a ray of light not but I
don't know I don't feel like I have the
words to describe all the things that
she had that really you know that she
brought to the character not only like
incredibly talented but when when we you
know filmed her the way she like
she lights up the screen it is that kind
of movie star quality that was just like
you're so watchable but also she could
do the teenage angst she could do the
vulnerability and there's a kind of
inherent goodness in what Priya emanates
as a performer which is incredible for
the character of Ria because Ria is
super annoying sometimes and you need
someone you can root for I know and she
has that and she just she took to the
fights like you know she could do the
physicality she's trying to save
people's lives man like let her be
annoying if she wants to
jobs are different
[Laughter]
she's on a mission
trying to Mission from God
yeah like The Blues Brothers
so can you talk about like your own
creative process and um how you approach
creating your characters
um
first of all I think
neither is honestly incredible she's a
genius I say this all the time
um but I I cannot stress it enough she
writes with such Nuance um it was so
easy to lift her off the page the script
really was my Bible you know when doing
this I could
um create her through your your
beautiful writing of her and and I was
so lucky as well to have rehearsal time
with another as well so we really got to
work together on her journey and really
a lot of what we did was like mapping
out how crazy and wired she is at every
given moment of the film
um I used to like write a lot about her
and I I wrote I I I just had like masses
of notebooks filled with pages about
things that I thought about her and her
life and I'd write cue cards on
literally every scene scenes that were
just me walking down a corridor like
what was she thinking what was her
adjective what was like this thing and
that thing that was going through her
head I even used to write letters to
yeah so you know just so many things no
I remember seeing all the work that
Priya did
um preparing for Aria and I've lived
with this character for 10 years in my
head and I honestly was worried that I
wouldn't be able to give it to an actor
because I'm like it's mine are you crazy
um but then when she comes on I I think
I was thanking you every day because I
felt like unburdened by by the character
because she was so thoughtful and you
put so much work in and is extremely
talented so I felt like oh I felt free
actually when you came on board so
thanks girl
so uh NADA this is your your first
feature film
um do you want to talk about what what
it was like doing
give us an impression of what what was
like having doing your first feature
project
think in the way I feel very lucky it
was a dream scenario in many in in a big
way because I had finished we are lady
Parts with working title and Tim Bevin a
working title was like do you have a
film we actually usually make films here
and I was like oh I do have this film
which had been passed by you know passed
on by everyone in the UK industry and he
was like oh this is mad I was like oh
yeah and he's like you should make it
more mad and I was like oh great so he
just really empowered me to like just
push it even further and I got to bring
on so many of my heads of Department
from we are lady parts to this I had the
same producers so there was like an
extra like an amazing continuity so I
didn't feel the step up as it were that
much in the making of it it felt just
like oh we got a bit a few more toys to
play with a bit more time it's just
actually in the edit but then I had we
had a longer edit time we had to do test
screenings I'm like oh it's Studio
moving we have to test it to make sure
audiences like it so we can sell tick
you know then I felt the machine really
come into play in post but actually I
feel like we really benefited from the
test screening because it's a Bonkers
film because it's got all this tonal
mishmashing we need to feel I needed to
feel it with audiences and see where I
could just improve it and hone it and
fine tune the tone and that you know
that was so much in the edit
do you for each of you
do you have a particularly memorable day
of difficulty
or or
conversely a day of that's just
memorable for other reasons
I loved shooting the gym Heist
huh just as brown Mario
was just constantly every time she went
past anyone at the crew we just went
back
um and you smashed it with that Swagger
we're like
very regularly I love it that none of
those dudes in the gym Walker room like
batted and I
[Laughter]
I was I think we were all Bonkers and I
always couldn't like keep keep it
together when we were shooting the gym
yeah that was really hard to keep a
straight face in it was definitely one
of the times I remember I like convinced
myself that if I couldn't get through a
take I'd be fired so I'd actually stop
laughing
um but yeah no that was really fun I
feel in terms of challenging I think one
of the really interesting things about
this film as well is like obviously how
somebody called it genre fluid which I
thought was a really cool term to use in
this and and
um yeah I really think that speaks True
to this and and I remember one day like
I came in we had half an hour in half an
hour I learned an entire fight sequence
which was the fight sequence of the um
rear fighting off the masseuses uh or
numerous um nimris Mansion I mean
rahila's mansion and um I learned the
fight in half an hour he shot that for
like four hours we had lunch break I
came back and then shot the scene where
basically Ria cries for three years
because her sister tells her she's not
gonna be a stunt woman and then the rest
of the evening we spent out in the
freezing cold me like running around the
Mansion being like a crazy kid and I was
like to jump from so many different
genres to jump from so many important
moments in the film and to be able to
Showcase skill in so many different ways
um was like a really challenging day so
incredible you had an entire dance
routine as well yeah
had you danced before it was a was it
particularly difficult to learn the
dance routine or
actually I found that easier than the
fights
um so
I have done dance in my life before I
will I'm no by no means a professional
time so
um but I I did apparent nadium for
anyone that knows um when I was younger
and also did bits of Gothic Bollywood
dance Street commercial as I was growing
up I've always loved performance so
um for me dance comes a little bit more
naturally than the martial arts
um and we got to work with an incredible
choreographer in the league
um in in London and she choreographed
the whole fight and the the most fun as
well was to bring rear into it because
she just adds her own little crazy as
somebody who grew up watching Bollywood
films and I distinctly remember watching
devdas when I was younger and to be able
to recreate that scene honestly was a
dream come true but and like to put a
little extra rare Twist on it which just
made it very fun
I wondered if there was going to be a
moment where someone was going to break
out into song like like Bollywood stuff
I'm like okay we're at a wedding
It's gotta happen so it was really
excited when there was a dance number
um
so uh yeah I love that genre fluid
I love that when I was watching the
second time I was trying to think of all
the genres that come up for me when I
was watching it definitely Bollywood
Kung Fu I think I remember reading that
you like Kung Fu movies a lot right
was there a particular kung fu movie you
wanted to emulate for this
I mean I think my first real kind of
experience of kung fu was watching The
Matrix when I was like 11 and not just
blowing my mind and then you watch the
making of and then that opens up actual
Hong Kong Kung Fu and Jet Li movies and
you know whooping films and like you
know I loved the balletic nature of
those films but also I thought there was
a real you know closeness to the
Bollywood I grew up on there's like
spectacle Cinema event Cinema you go you
know the experience of
just entertainment and spectacle was
something I think I just it was part of
the cinema I grew up on and Hong Kong
Kung Fu spoke to that really I think
that's why the two things you know the
wedding sequence at the end I wanted to
bring the kind of the the fun kind of
absurd Bollywood tenored you know yeah
over the topness with the kind of kung
fu I love that was such a joyful thing
to do but you know speaking of genres I
grew up also really loving teen movies
especially American teen movies as sort
of the groundedness the respect of the
teenager who's talked about slums of
Beverly Hills are being like one of my
favorite all-time favorite team movies
and just like the truth of what it means
to be a teenage girl
um but you know also like Donnie Darko
it goes down that sort of team but
bringing that in with ball you know it's
all it's a Kind of Love Letter to the
films I loved and you know thinking of
making a film that my teenage self would
really like right and the way we me and
my dop Ashley Connor approached it was
like this is a film that is made by Ria
Khan so it needs to film like a feel
like a teenager making a movie which
also got us out of jail a few times like
was that in focus it doesn't matter it's
teenagers film uh she made it
real will fix it in post she'll fix it
depressed exactly
um
well so uh is there uh sorry I lost my
place on this
um I get a little brother sometimes
um
so with we are lady Parts I wanted to
actually with the themes of this film uh
I wanted to talk about what the themes
of this film are and
um how they reflect
um your feelings about things
um with both this film and we are lady
Parts as explorations of of women being
forced into marriage or obsessed with
Merit like freely obsessed with wanting
to marry which seems to be a lot of
questions around relationships and
expectations around women and
relationships
yeah you know
I can speak for myself as a filmmaker
and I realized as I kind of think about
it I always I definitely felt the
pressure of being the good girl growing
up and like performing a certain way of
being that is sort of polite
um you know just sort of staying in my
box don't upset the apple cop being the
kind of good daughter getting the good
job and just really feeling the pressure
of that
um and I really realized in my art in we
are lady Parts in polite Society I
wanted to explore a kind of the Anarchy
I was feeling that the rage the the kind
of desire to be an artist which I didn't
feel I was being you know was something
that was supported in the kind of
culture I grew up in so so much of that
angst kind of comes through in the work
and also as I've been reflecting on the
comparing we are lady parts to polite
Society we are lady Parts is about a
band a punk band playing instruments
it's a kind of physicality to what they
do polite Society is an action movie
about women being physical in their body
days you know and again I think as a
teenage girl I remember this moment
where I felt like I kind of divided from
my body where you go from being a child
to them being objectified and like the
strange feeling of not feeling one with
yourself and I felt like with you know
women playing music and women fighting
it's sort of you kind of get to be one
with you there's a physicality to that
and I realize there's something in that
in that of like yeah expressing oneself
in including an embodied way of being
that I I really see in both pieces of
work
we are lady Parts I was re-watching it
recently again it made me think of when
I got into Riot girl music
because bridegirl music is great but
also when you sort of listen to the
lyrics and get into the ideology of it
and it's like these women do have a lot
to rage about you know it's like oh I
wouldn't think of like um British Muslim
women having a punk band but I was like
wait they have the most rage the most
reason to rage out and have a punk band
and and the same with this
you know you wouldn't
think to find these people in an action
film
or you know beating each other up
knowing martial arts but you do and I
love the way that your projects find a
way for all these things to exist
together
I love that you're exploring that
so um can you either of you talk about
either or both talk about what you have
might have coming up next
you're like no
well I've got lady Parts series too
which I'm furiously writing yeah oh my
God you're doing another season yeah
another series that's that's happening
also um which I'm really excited about
um more fun music but you know it's been
such a joy to do action and explore
femininity and Womanhood through the
genre and actually use the genre to like
explore what it feels like to be a
teenage girl and I want to ex just yeah
I want to continue to work in action and
see how I can bring kind of Outsider
stories into this space and really kind
of Center women of color and
and you know I enjoy big spectacle I
enjoy genre enjoy yeah again using genre
and yeah bringing stories from a
different point of view into mainstream
genre big genre fun
um and let's see you know it's the
opening weekend this weekend I hope you
guys go out and see it encourage your
friends
it because you know if if it does well
at the box office it really helps more
stories get supported in the cinema it
helps us get absolutely yeah
would be awesome go support guys that's
amazing
pretty
do you have Bridgerton Part 12 coming
out part 12.
um I will not be in the next season of
Bridgeton but I'm really excited for
what they're doing and
um yeah can't wait to watch it and
obviously there's like lots of trickling
conversations so hopefully um in the
coming months there'll be a lot more to
share about next steps and new Journeys
so yeah basically after this comes out
Priya is going to be non-affordable so
none of you guys will be able to look
her in the eyes
I'm always like please work with me
again you promise
and you have to promise I like to study
too baby
well
congratulations uh on this film and
thank you so much to the two of you for
coming out to tacos tonight thank you a
pleasure thank you thank you everyone
foreign
[Music]